so cancel answer yeah guns like a smoke
must rise over the subtle of venison at
just the right moment then photographer
Annalise can release the shutter he and
his crew spent weeks in the photo studio
this time the theme is barbecuing
perfect the team includes a chef and a
food stylist the publisher and many
assistants it takes a year and a half to
get from the initial concept to the
photo shoot the first quality controls
occur in the studio they'll take
hundreds of shots of the saddle of
venison alone visit a heel manga and
here we're doing a book about barbecuing
and smoking it's a more manly topic so
we've opted for darker colors as you can
see in the layouts this is a classical
work breakdown structure here's where
the ingredients are to be shot it's like
a storyboard so you know when each scene
should be developed interesting soil
gets us off before each production costs
several hundred thousand euros the price
of a single-family house and Germany but
that's because these are the Mercedes of
cookbooks yep me know and pulse 11 he's
not just a book when I touch it or run
my hand over it it's an experience not
the ID at first there's the materials
you want to measure this edition for
example has a relief lacquer that's
raised and soft to the touch but they
also have things like inlaid symbols I
medium laser which is made from laser
cut steel our clients want something
special they want to be surprised but
the crew is hoping there won't be any
surprises when it comes to the salmon
the food stylist is preparing the fish
for the photo shoot is to be smoked over
cedar on location everything should look
as realistic as possible the food isn't
artificially touched up
these cookbooks are authentically a
german-made products the books are even
printed in Germany but how do they make
cooking look exciting ina give this a
lock items the pictures can't be too
formal people looking at them should
always feel like they'd like to eat the
food when a picture for a recipe is
arranged in a boring way you don't look
at it for too long skip did however food
photos can be very minimalist he had
expressed a great deal my Zion about an
agenda gusta also a consultation nothing
is left to chance the sumptuous
cookbooks are destined to become
classics the book about pastry sold for
30 years and remained virtually
unchanged that's how the publisher
finances the project the books are not
instant best sellers but make money over
the long term that's why the meticulous
preparation is so vital yeah and it is
yeah food photography most money some as
a food photographer you firstly have to
love food by son says otherwise you
can't bring things across properly we
were plain and want but you're so slim
you are by leibish one yes but I love
good food this has got nothing to do
with my body banker and I love many
different kinds of food keep Afghans
fish eating a form form from Islam the
cookbooks are purchased by clients
around the globe international rights
have already been sold for 23 countries
there's also interest in Russia and the
Arab speaking world
much attention is given to the
ingredients whereas the sausage come
from what is it made of four weeks are
spent cooking and photographing the
results in the end even ordinary sausage
becomes a work of art
you